>>> SINCE LEAVING THE WHITE
HOUSE MORE THAN 12 YEARS AGO
NOW, FORMER PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH HAS TRIED TO STAY OUT OF
POLITICS.
BUT THAT'S CHANGING IN HIS NEW
BOOK "OUT OF MANY ONE."
MR. BUSH IS LENDING HIS VOICE TO
ONE OF THE MOST CONTENTIOUS
ISSUES IN THE NATION NOW --
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THE BOOK FEATURES 43 PORTRAITS
OF IMMIGRANTS PAINTED BY THE
43rd PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
EACH PAINTING TELLS THE STORY OF
THAT IMMIGRANT, AND OUR CBS NEWS
ANCHOR AND MANAGING EDITOR NORAH
O'DONNELL VISITED THE BUSH
FAMILY RANCH IN CRAWFORD, TEXAS,
HOME OF MR. BUSH'S ART STUDIO,
TO LEARN MORE EARLIER THIS
MONTH.
>> FIRST IMMIGRANT YOU KNEW?
>> FIRST IMMIGRANT I KNEW.
>> BAOLA FRIENDON.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> ONE OF THE IMMIGRANTS MAY NOT
BE FAMOUS TO THE REST OF US, BUT
SHE'S ONE OF THE MOST TREASURED
PEOPE IN THE BUSH FAMILY.
>> I WAS 13 YEARS OLD.
MOTHER AND DAD HIRED HER TO COME
AND HELP WITH OUR FAMILY.
SHE LEFT THREE KIDS BEHIND IN
MEXICO.
I'LL NEVER FORGET OPENING THE
DOORS, POURING RAIN IN HOUSTON,
AND THERE SHE WAS.
TINY LITTLE WOMAN, HUDDLED AND
SCARED TO DEATH.
AND SHE TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS AND DREAMS.
>> PRESIDENT BUSH DOESN'T JUST
PAINT IMMIGRANTS --
YOU'RE IN THE TREE FARMING
BUSINESS?
>> YEAH, BABY.
WE'RE SELLING TREES.
>> HE EMPLOYS THEM TO WORK ON
HIS 90-ACRE TREE FARM.
>> THERE ARE EIGHT MEXICAN GUYS
WORKING ON THE TREE FARM HERE
BECAUSE OF THE WORKER VISAS.
AND THEY'RE INCREDIBLY GOOD
WORKERS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IS THEY'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEY SEND MONEY BACK HOME.
>> IN YOUR SECOND RUN FOR
OFFICE, YOU WON 44% OF THE
HISPANIC VOTE.
>> SI.
>> YES.
NO REPUBLICAN HAS MATCHED THAT.
>> SI.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY CAN STILL WIN IF IT DOES
NOT WELCOME HISPANIC VOTERS?
>> I THINK THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY'S VALUES ARE SHARED BY
MOST LATINO VOTERS.
I THINK THAT IT REQUIRES LEADERS
AND CANDIDATES TO SAY "I CARE
ABOUT YOU," YOU KNOW, NOT ONLY
DO I WANT YOUR VOTE, I WANT YOU
TO BE -- FEEL COMFORTABLE ABOUT
WHAT AMERICA OFFERS ALL
CITIZENS.
>> PRESIDENT BUSH HOPES GETTING
BACK INTO THE IMMIGRATION DEBATE
WILL CHANGE THE TONE.
NOT JUST IN HIS PARTY BUT ACROSS
THE NATION.
NORAH O'DONNELL, CBS NEWS,
CRAWFORD, TEXAS.
>> WHAT A VERY PERSONAL AND
INTERESTING WAY TO ENTER THE
DISCUSSION.
>> YEAH, BABY.
WE'RE SELLING TREES.
>> WE'RE SELLING TREES.
>> YEAH --
>> I LOVE THAT --
>> THERE'S THAT.
BUT I MEAN, DOING A BOOK OF
PAINTINGS ON IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT A GREAT IDEA.
>> THEY LOOKED GOOD, TOO.
HE DOES SEEM TO BE ENJOYING HIS
NEXT CHAPTER.
>> YEAH.
>> OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WAS SUCH A CUTE SHOT OF NORAH
AND MR. AND MRS. BUSH HAVING A
GREAT CONVERSATION.
NICELY DONE.
>> SELLING TREES --
>>